[Music]
you talked about reasons to close
schools even if kids there aren't sick
yeah I mean school closures there's a
lot of debate about this there are two
kinds of school closures and most of the
countries shutting the schools anyway
now so this point is is behind us I was
sending out this information like three
or four weeks ago but school closures
are two kinds there's reactive school
closure when there's a case in the
school and you close the school and
that's pretty uncontroversial I mean
most parents teachers public health
experts there's an outbreak epidemic in
the school
let's close to school demand it's been
shown that if you do that you lower the
if you close the schools in an in an
area you lower the cumulative prevalence
of the condition by about 25 percent and
postpone the epidemic by a week or two
which is good so reactive school closure
is helpful but you know it's not as good
as we can do that even better is
something called proactive school
closure when you close the schools even
before there's a case in the schools for
instance you living in a mid-sized town
there's a case in the community it's
something called a community-acquired
case so it's not like someone from Italy
or China flew to your town landed had
symptoms and you diagnosed them that
would be an imported case maybe you
could isolate that person and and and
self-quarantine the people who they
connected with no we're talking about a
situation in which someone in the
community is diagnosed and we have no
idea where they got it they're like a
canary in the coal mine and if that's
happening you can be quite confident
that within a week or two it's gonna be
in the school so why not close the
school now reduce the force of the
epidemic by decreasing social mixing and
ironically even though the kids aren't
affected by this condition they still
can transmit the pathogen even though
they themselves aren't sick and
furthermore one of the ways that school
closure works is precisely because it
compels the parents to stay home so it
reduces the parents interacting with
each other
that's how it works in part yeah and it
sounds like we've we've basically done
this pretty well maybe a little later
than you wanted to
but it sounds like now we're there right
now definitely definitely later than we
wanted to and for schools that are still
open what I would strongly recommend and
my wife and I had an article in the
Atlantic about this a few days ago is if
you insist on staying open and I don't
think that's the best course of action
at least you can implement a whole host
of other harm mitigation strategies for
example give parents the choice if they
want to keep their kids home they should
stay home I want to mention this because
it's also relevant to employers and
workers allowing any worker who can work
at home to work at home it's not just
good for that worker from like their
selfish point of view it helps everybody
because you reduce the number of people
at the office so only the people that
have to be there should be there same
with schools if some parents want to
keep the school should let them keep
their kids home you can broaden drop-off
and pickup hours so not everyone is
arriving between 8 and 8:15 to drop off
their kids bumping against each other as
they come through the door
parents interacting let's say you give a
45 minute drop-off it needs a bit more
manpower on the part of the school but
you reduce the social density at pickup
and drop off cancel staff meetings
provide cafeteria seating broaden the
lunch hour and have the kids sit every
other chair these are things that
schools can do if they insist on staying
open maybe in our southern states for
instance where maybe the virus hasn't
hit so much yet but that nevertheless
are helpful Hebburn we're obviously in
some unchartered territory with
coronavirus and our plan here is to help
you make as much sense of the situation
and a non alarmist fashion as possible
if you're looking for reliable
information from experts on the
frontlines of the pandemic check out our
coronavirus playlist which will keep
adding updates - right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe